elle s'exprime extrêmement bien c'est
rigolo j'avais pas cette impression à
l'époque jusqu'à ce que je me révolte il
y a quelques mois j'ai été dans la même
situation mais c'est ce que j'ai pu
constater en fait c'est que c'est
toujours un problème un problème
d'actualité elle a dû avoir tout le
monde sur le dos en rentrant à la maison
à la maison ça a vraiment été perçu
comme une blague c'est révoltant en plus
elle se fait engueuler qui es-tu devenu
jolie Aziza et ben je vais bien
libellule je suis devenue éducatrice
spécialisée infirmière maman de deux
enfants je suis en bon terme avec mes
trois grands frères on se voit
régulièrement pour des repas de famille
elle me fait penser à l'ENA situation je
suis désolée j'ai pas compris vous
connaissez pas les ma situation oh non
mince je suis out alors attendez
le féminisme bravo bah c'est un joli
compliment c'est le plus important en
fait c'est c'est de défendre les choses
avec son cœur et son âme pour notre
génération ou la génération à